well we all know don't we uh why
the united states went into the gulf we
were responding to
naked aggression we were
preserving and defending quote unquote
our way of life
uh jobs were at stake you remember that
one from baker
and then it was a return to stopping
naked aggression
uh and that aggression cannot be
rewarded
we all know that we responded from moral
principle
and from political principle
we also know that bush went into the
persian gulf
in order to restore to his throne
the emir or dictator of kuwait
and here we have seen just recently his
return
and the development of kuwait or the
return to kuwait of that
principled democratic system they have
there of based on
what we all treasure one man one vote
one vote by the emir
well there are
alternative explanations i think in
analyses
of why we went into the persian gulf
one that we haven't seen really in any
uh
meaningful way is the interpretation
that a crisis was needed
to replace the crisis in western europe
the east west crisis which largely
disappeared with the collapse of
communism in eastern europe
a crisis that would allow for the
continuation of the
40 odd-year-old war economy in the
united states
wherein more than half the budget the
federal budget
is taken up with military expenditures
you know that the official figure for
1990
was 26 percent of the national budget
going to
military expenditures but that 26
percent is very convenient for those who
want to cover it up because
they do not factor into that 20 percent
or 26 percent
many of the most important military
costs
such as interest on the national debt
from past military expenditures
the retirement benefits for tens of
thousands of
former department of defense employees
civilian employees
and many other items analysts who have
studied this the matter have come up
with figures going up to fifty five to
sixty percent
people like gorvy dahl puts it at two
thirds the federal budget
going for national defense well that is
a system which was certainly at risk
wasn't it with the collapse of communism
in in europe and the only reason that
that could have been kept going all
through these years
has been of course the so-called soviet
threat or the
permanent crisis atmosphere that
developed
following 1950 in the korean war
there is plenty of evidence to suggest
that bush wanted this crisis
and that the bush administration policy
was to
encourage saddam hussein and his party
to believe that they could take over
kuwait or either in whole or in part
with impunity consider the following
iraq already had historical claims over
kuwait
for several centuries kuwait had been
the southern
part of the basra province of the
ottoman empire under the turks
and when after world war ii with the
collapse of the ottoman empire
kuwait was severed from basra the iraqis
did not accept it
the british at that time had moved in as
the french did in other parts of the
middle east in order to fill the vacuum
left with the collapse
of the turkish empire the british in
1922
drew the first lines in the sand
delineating boundaries for the first
time
in history between jordan iraq kuwait
and saudi arabia these lines drawn by
sir percy cox in 1922 he was the british
high commissioner in baghdad
these lines were drawn uh deliberately
to deprive
iraq of a viable seaport
the british wanted no competition from
baghdad which was at that time the
uh cultural and commercial capital of
the gulf region
to their dominance of the persian gulf
where they converted no less than 10
shakedoms into colonies including
kuwait
when kuwait was given its independence
by the british in 1961
the iraqis mass troops on the border
and threatened to take the territory
back by force
but britain rushed military forces to
kuwait
and the iraqis backed down the iraqis
threatened to do the very same thing
in 1972 in 1976.
so there were historical iraqi claims on
kuwait
there were also immediate grievances
based
partly on kuwaiti overproduction of
petroleum
in 1986 the opec countries had set 18
per barrel as the bench price for uh for
the world petroleum market
but the kuwaitis and the united arab
emirates for
quite a long time since then had been
over producing forcing the price down
as low as about thirteen dollars last
june
that price was the best price that
industrialized countries and importers
like the united states
were paying for petroleum at constant
dollars for more than
40 years it was hurting the iraqi
economy because the iraqis had
something like 70 to 80 billion dollars
in debt
from their war their eight-year war with
iran during the 1980s
and they were demanding that the iraqis
forgive those
loans uh which had helped finance that
war
so there are a number of different
immediate grievances another one was the
theft of petroleum from
iraq's brumaila field which is this vast
oil field dipping
into disputed territory between iraq and
kuwait
in april the assistant secretary of
state for middle eastern affairs
a man whose name is john kelly testified
before
the u s congress that the united states
had no
commitment to defend kuwait
in july the opec oil ministers met in
geneva that's mid-july
and iraq was demanding a
raise in the oil price and also the
uh the elimination of overproduction on
the part of kuwait and the emirates
iraq at that time messed 30 000 troops
on the kuwaiti border
hussein got part of what he wanted the
uh the
emirates in kuwait agreed to stop over
producing new quotas were set in order
to
maintain a new price of twenty one
dollars per barrel
even though iraq had asked for twenty
five in any case
things uh were not settled even with
that
because iraq was continuing to demand
that kuwait lease to iraq
two small islands boubian and warba in
the at the head of the persian gulf
which would have
provided iraq with a viable seaport
kuwait refused kuwait also refused to
forgive the loans that had been made to
finance iraq's war with iran
negotiators met in saudi arabia between
the two countries on the 1st of august
kuwait did not compromise and the next
day saddam hussein invaded
while the united states was not unaware
that this was coming by any means
on april 25th some of you have read this
i'm sure
on apr i mean on july 25th april glaspie
the u.s ambassador to iraq
had a meeting a face-to-face meeting
with saddam hussein at that meeting
she said according to a transcript
apparently the iraqis
recorded the conversation secretly and
later made available the transcript
a transcript which by the way has not
been disputed by the department of state
at this meeting the u.s ambassador said
to saddam hussein
i have a direct instruction from the
secretary of state
to emphasize to you that the united
states has
quote unquote no opinion on your border
disputes
with kuwait she also said
i have an instruction from the president
to seek better relations
with iraq at this time there were 100
000 iraqi troops
poised on the border because after the
opec conference in geneva
in geneva in mid july the iraqis did not
withdraw those 30 000 troops they more
than tripled them
to something like 100 000. during this
time also in the days
following uh or the week following uh
the ambassador's meeting with hussein
up to the invasion the cia according to
press reports and according to senator
boren
who is the chairman of the senate
intelligence committee the cia was
predicting
that iraq would invade kuwait and in
fact
in the meeting between the u.s
ambassador and hussein
hussein himself responded to her saying
in effect
that he was going to take drastic action
against kuwait
if they did not agree to his demands so
it was as clear as
crystal i believe that hussein was going
to
invade kuwait but during the that week
that crucial week between the
ambassadors meeting with hussein
and the invasion with those one hundred
thousand iraqi troops on the border
the bush administration did absolutely
nothing and there were things they could
have done
they could have called for example a an
emergency meeting of the
united nations security council they
could have sent a multinational military
force
to kuwait to defend that country just as
the british had done
earlier they could have issued public
warnings
but they did something to the contrary
they prohibited
the united states information agency
from
making a warning to hussein on a program
that had been scheduled
the assistant secretary of state john
kelly himself uh killed that program
and forbid any u s government warnings
to hussein or to the thousands of people
who might become
hostages in the event of an invasion of
kuwait
then two days before the invasion the
same assistant secretary of state john
kelly
goes before the congress one more time
and again he says
the united states has no commitment to
defend kuwait
well put all those things together and
it certainly seems to add up
to a situation in which the united
states was enticing
or encouraging hussein to take over
kuwait
in order to create a new international
crisis
in a key position of the world certainly
if hussein took over kuwait
he would control then
20 percent of the known petroleum
reserves in the world
a concentration in radical nationalist
arab hands that would be too great to be
accepted by any western industrialized
country and even by iraq's
principal arms supplier the soviet union
well when bush came out with the remark
very early on
that quote our way of life is at stake
he reminded me quite clearly of
something that president truman had said
back
in 1950 you know the decision was taken
in 1950 to establish a permanent war
economy that is to
make military expenditures the motor of
the u s economy
it was because there was tremendous fear
that we were heading back to the
conditions of the depression
of the 1930s during those first five
years
after the end of world war ii up to 1950
the united states economy had contracted
or the gnp had
declined by 20 percent and unemployment
which had been almost nothing in 1945
700
000 had gone up to 4.7 million
the highest echelons of the truman
administration
considered the problem and decided that
the way to
avoid a return to the condition of the
1930s was military expenditures
re-armament in the united states and in
western europe the entire plan was drawn
up in a document called nsc 68
nsc standing for national security
council it was it was written by paul
nixie
who was then the uh chief of the policy
planning staff
of the department of state this is about
a 40-page document was top secret for 25
years
and released only by accident in 1975
and published
my version of it which comes from the
naval war college magazine
runs to about forty eight or fifty pages
it's a world analysis
and the u s role in the world
uh the key quote from that document
was the united states and other free
nations
will within a period of a few years at
most
experience a decline in economic
activity
of serious proportions unless more
positive governmental
programs are developed well the solution
adopted the more positive governmental
programs
was the re-arming not only of the united
states but also of western europe
the problem we faced at that time uh
from an economic point of view
was that united states exports were not
sufficient to sustain the economy
and the subsidy program known as the
marshall plan
having failed there had to be other ways
to get enough dollars over to western
europe
to foment european imports from the
united states
that would sustain the u s economy and
re-militarization of western europe with
germany west germany as the key pivotal
country was
adopted the money was transferred then
in billions of dollars
through so-called defense support grants
and
the economic syste situation in the
united states
was saved at least through that method
and we have been with this permanent war
economy ever since of course
it took a crisis it took a threat and
the department of state and other
agencies set about to create that
permanent crisis atmosphere to create
the soviet union as
a threat to our way of life
but because there was so much money
involved truman could not get the money
from congress
uh right away it took the korean war a
real crisis
to enable him to defeat
congressional opposition and get the
money the war
you know started in june 1950 and by
september the allied troops with which
the united states had formed under a
an alliance and under the u n banner
very similar to the gulf crisis
uh had forced the north koreans back up
to the 38th parallel the boundary
and that is what the u n sanctions
called for for expelling north korea
from south korea
that would have ended the war right then
and there three months after it started
if truman had accepted a soviet proposal
in the united nations
but he had to keep this crisis going
because he needed to use the
korean war to overcome congressional
opposition to this
rearmament program he had another plan
he in he violated the u.n
the u.n charter or the u.n uh
resolutions in fact by invading north
korea
uh threatening to overthrow the
communist government of north korea
and reunite the country under the
dictatorship that the united states had
imposed in the south
well the chinese said they were going to
come into the war if that advance
toward the yalu river the boundary
between north korea and china was not
stopped
truman did not stop the forces the
chinese entered and by november u s
forces were again retreating south
by december the newspapers hear that all
the media were full of stories and
pictures
of retreating u.s troops before
hordes of advancing chinese communist
troops
it was then early december that truman
went on national radio
he declared a state of national
emergency
and he said what bush's remarks about
our way of life being at stake
reminded me of
truman mustered all the hype and emotion
that he could
and he said our homes
our nation all the things that we
believe in
are in great danger this danger has been
created by the rulers
of the soviet union well he also called
at that time for
massive increases in u.s rearmament
expenditures and for
the rearmament of western europe
he got the money then but of course the
soviet was not a threat at all they were
still rebuilding from the rubble of
world war
ii where they had lost something like 20
million people they were not a threat
but this was part of the whole scenario
to create the international crisis the
international threat
in order to justify the militarism which
truman was
beginning and he got the money he wanted
the
in two years from 1950 to 1952
the u s military budget more than
tripled from 13 billion
in 1950 to 44 billion in 1952
and u.s military forces doubled to
3.6 million people from that time on
we have lived in the united states with
this
military economy and that is the thing
that bush
i think in the gulf wanted to save he
had to have another
crisis as i've said uh twice already he
had to have another crisis to replace
the
one that disappeared in western europe
well in the cold war you know
there was a there were several
dimensions
a lot of people you will hear say the
cold war is over
well i say to those who think the cold
war is over that they should think
uh once more the east west dimension
in western europe between the united
states and nato and the soviet union and
the warsaw pact
that east-west dimension in europe has
indeed largely disappeared
but there was always a north-south
dimension of the cold war and that is
the
war against the so-called third world
that is in fact where the fighting
really took place as in vietnam
this new world order or new
international order
that bush is talking about looks to me
like a an institutionalization or
attempt to
institutionalize the north south
dimension
of the old cold war which was a war for
natural resources
for labor and for markets
and our dependence this uh that is the
western dependence and especially
the united states economic dependence on
the natural resources
of third world countries is certainly
not going to disappear
we need still to attempt to control
those resources
and this gulf intervention of course is
not at all about stopping naked
aggression
we have produced naked aggression we
have con connived in naked aggression we
have
encouraged naked aggression in many
different ways
and that naked aggression that we have
encouraged has often been very well
rewarded
take turkey's occupation since the 1970s
a one-third
of cyprus they have received something
like nine billion dollars
in usaid the israelis are now at this
very moment occupying the
the territories their occupied part
occupying part of syria and part of
lebanon
there are many different examples
indonesia's takeover of east timor in
the 1970s
the united states even encouraged that
and uh
an enormous it may have been 10 or 15
percent of the population of
east timor was killed in the indonesian
suppression of their
independence they had been a portuguese
colony up until the indonesians tried to
annex them
many of us have seen the discussion
going on
about who should pay for this how much
the germans should pay
how much the japanese should pay how
much should be paid to countries whose
economies were affected by the
uh war turkey jordan egypt for example
this always seemed like such a false
argument to me
the kuwaitis have more than 100 billion
dollars
invested outside their country through
kyo
kio the kuwait investment office based
in london
with uh branches in new york and madrid
and paris and all over they have more
than one billion dollar
100 billion dollars invested abroad and
they have enormous petroleum reserves
i think they can keep on pumping for
probably another
hundred years and they won't run out
they will certainly have enough to pay
from past earnings and from future
earnings
the saudis the same we went there first
to defend the saudi
regime and the saudi uh natural
resources petroleum
they too are making enough money from it
to pay all the cost there is no reason
why one
american should pay one cent for that
operation
those countries should pay and that
would conform with reality
wherein united states military forces
have been exported abroad like one more
export
we used to export you know simply the
hardware
tanks aircraft and so forth but this
time we sent across the hardware
and the people to operate it that turned
it into a classic
mercenary operation the sending abroad
of military forces to defend a foreign
regime
and i don't say mercenary in a totally
derogatory sense because
george washington may not have won the
war for independence against
uh britain if it hadn't been for the
hessian mercenaries
who came over and fought at his side
well the cia of course was a very
important tool in the cold war
and certainly it was important in
building up saddam hussein
in iraq i suppose most of you have read
already that the
united states in its support for iraq
all during that
war with iran was giving iraq the best
intelligence possible
on iranian troop movements it was
uh what i've read is that they were
giving them uh real-time
satellite information so that they could
confront
and defeat the iranian forces in that
war
i even read one very good report from
the washington post
that the c i a office in baghdad became
much more important than the
ambassador's own office
because that is the office where the
iraqis wanted to
deal most but the question arises when
we talk about these foreign
interventions whether they are the
secret interventions
for the support of death squads and
torture or
whether it is in the sending of 500 000
troops
to smash a third world country that got
out of line
we still have to ask the question why do
we do these things
in whose interest are these activities
when i was a trainee in the c i a i was
taught
that the soviet union's foreign policy
its expansionism its belligerence
was a direct product of the domestic
system in the soviet union
the requirements of the soviet communist
party
to retain a monopoly on power i think
any political scientist would agree
that a society's or a nation's domestic
policy
is a direct product of its domestic
system so if we want to answer the
question of why we do these grizzly
things abroad
like like hosing all those
retreating iraqi soldiers who had no way
of defending themselves
killing between 100 thousand and two
hundred thousand people
when when we wanna ask answer the
question of why we do these things
abroad
we have to come back i think and look at
the domestic system in this country
and this system of course is a system in
great crisis
bush called the persian gulf crisis the
greatest
crisis since world war ii remember that
the greatest
moral crisis since world war two well of
course he was totally wrong
the greatest crisis in world war two is
the domestic crisis in the united states
in education in health care
we all know what the domestic crisis is
in this country it is
racism it is drugs it is violence of
every sort
it is the worst educational system in
the
developed world it is a system in which
one in three people is living in poverty
either totally or in absolute poverty or
so close that they have no
relief from want where one in three
people is illiterate
either totally or to the degree that
they cannot function or get along in a
society based on the written word
and we have a system in which one in
three americans does not even register
to vote
and if those who do register twenty
percent of them don't vote
meaning that only about fifty percent of
the potential voters vote in national
elections in this country
therein we elect a president with about
24 or 25 percent
of the potential vote we don't have
popular participation even
in the political process well this is
i hate to say the way it's supposed to
be when i came back to the united states
in 1987 for the first time in 17
years you remember what we were doing
don't you
we were celebrating the 200th
anniversary of the constitution
i watched all that orgy of
self-congratulation that year
and it reminded me of a passage in one
of noam chomsky's uh
books turning the tide on central
america
in that book he discussed the
constitutional convention of 1787 in
philadelphia
where 55 men got together in total
secrecy
not one word was revealed until more
than fifty years after the convention
one word of what was said there to find
solutions to problems in governing the
united states under the articles of
confederation
the question arose as chomsky wrote
who really is to govern the united
states
and john jay had the answer you remember
john jay was the president of the
continental congress that fought the war
for independence
and he was also the first chief justice
of the united states of the supreme
court
john jay had the answer he said well of
course the people who
own the united states ought to govern it
and so they wrote the constitution at
his suggestion
they wrote out of the political process
something like 95 percent
of the inhabitants of the united states
democracy was the last thing they had in
mind
in writing the constitution there is a
book up here called
toward an american revolution it's by
jerry frazier
a phd from umass at amherst which i tell
people
would be the best ten dollars they could
spend on a book during their four five
or six years in university
because that is the story of how the
constitution was adopted and who the
people were who wrote it
they were the elite of colonial society
the lawyers the merchants
the uh bankers the slaveholders the
landowners and so forth
the wealthy people and they wrote it to
protect
their wealth they wrote it to enshrine
what is still
the first human right in the united
states all
others are secondary the first human
right here
is to accumulate wealth and
the power that goes with it all
others like the right to life the right
to
education the right to housing the right
to a job the right to proper health care
all those are secondary the constitution
enshrined
that one right before any other
well i highly recommend fraise's book
that constitution really is the root of
the problem of the of the domestic
crisis that we have today in my opinion
there have been some 25 amendments
amendments
and a lot of legislation over these 200
years but the rules of the game as laid
down in the constitution are the same as
they were at the beginning
it was the original pact between the
political forces to keep the
political debate in the united states as
narrow as possible
and to make those rules of the game as
hard to change
as possible it's the rule of the
situation when we go
out and vote today and we're selecting
between republicans and democrats
we're really only choosing between on
the one hand tweedle dumb
and on the other tweedledee and
there are there are of course many
people who would like to see a
i sometimes say third and make a mistake
a second party
in the united states and that would be
possible but
this domestic crisis crisis makes it
very difficult
if we solve the education problem and we
had
informed voters and participants in the
political process
if we solve health problems for example
if people
had a an attraction to the political
process
then there would be a real threat of
democracy
in this country and that is what is
behind in my opinion
the war economy in the first place the
continuation of the war economy
and the need for this crisis in the gulf
yes you use the word oligarchy
about south and central america where
you use can you talk about oligarchy
here in the united states
well uh i did mention this book by jerry
frazier toward american revolution
and those of course were the original
oligarchs weren't they
of this country uh
they have the system has continued of
course we have you know i used to think
that latin america
was uh terrible in terms of the dis
distribution of wealth and income
but then i learned from the catholic
bishops uh report on the economy
of 1987 i think it is that two percent
of american families own
54 percent of the net financial assets
of this country two percent of american
families own fifty four percent of the
net financial assets of this country
those are the people who really run the
united states of course
and they are the people for who that
whom the cia serves
as does bush and all those people in the
administration
and the professionals who service these
very wealthy people those of course are
our
version of the latin american oligarchs
we should also continue in international
solidarity as before
the fmln in el salvador and the fdr
they need arsenal solidarity as much as
they ever did
the same goes
the same goes for the fsln in nicaragua
and the same goes for cuba which is very
likely to be
seen as incompatible with bush's
new international order i've just spent
a week in cuba i came back from there
two weeks ago and i had probably the
most interesting trip i've had there in
the 20 years that i've been coming and
going and working in solidarity with the
revolution
they are in extreme crisis and they need
our help
and hope also that we can break the
information blockade on what is really
happening in cuba so that ordinary
americans who have a sense of decency
will see that this policy against cuba
for the last
how many years 30 at least 1960 yeah 30
years
is erroneous and that we ought to open
up trade
and commerce with cuba
one more thing that we can do certainly
on the campuses
and certainly on a campus like this
where there has been such a long
and important cia presence
is activism against the cia
on the campuses there certainly is no
there certainly is no justification in
allowing
for example murder incorporated to come
on the campuses
of the united states to recruit young
americans to go into that work
finally i might just mention this last
thursday
i participated in a press conference
with ramsey clark in new york at the u.n
in which he announced a war crimes
tribunal
which will be international in scope and
will seek to raise all the evidence
and information on war crimes committed
by the united states and its allies
against iraq this includes all of those
items which specifically fall under the
geneva conventions of 1949
including targeting civilian areas
targeting the life support civilian life
support system
of civilians such as water supply such
as electricity
such as sewage systems
killing retreating soldiers who have no
way to defend themselves
those kinds of things are all very
specifically uh spelled out
and this is uh just starting up now last
thursday the first delegation went to
amman five people to start collecting
information from refugees there
and it so happened that just a few days
ago i was speaking with a friend
who knows a family very well whose son
had written home from the gulf saying
that he had seen with his own eyes
u s soldiers executing iraqi
prisoners he wants to make that public
and
i urge all of you who know people who
are in the military who are over there
or who have relatives who somehow can
get the word out
if anyone wants to talk about what
happened
they have a place to go and this is to
this tribunal
well finally i would say that we
should and must spread the word
about bush's lies and his hypocrisy
on the gulf intervention and his bombing
of iraq
back to the pre-industrial age
for no reason but for his own
re-election
you know that last september and october
when we're having the elections
bush was saying the sanctions are
working but he realized
that for his own reelection they might
take more than two years to work
and come 1992 and the electoral campaign
he might be seen very much as jimmy
carter was seen in 1980
as hostage to a foreign crisis as weak
as indecisive and he made the decision
right then there i'm sure
to trade all these lives for his own
re-election because the sanctions would
have worked
no country has ever been blockaded by
the whole world
it was like an uh medieval city siege
and they would have worked but they
wouldn't perhaps have worked soon enough
for bush's reelection
we must reject his boast when 1992 comes
that he made the world safe from saddam
hussein and
we must eject him from the white house
in order to make the world safe from
george bush
i thank you all very much